so let's start with this very simple
exercise here you see different products
and how much revenue they contribute to
the total revenue of a company so the
sum of them all is 100 so what chart
type would you choose to visualize this
from my experience the chart type that
people will mentioned most frequently in
the situation is a pie chart so we
should surely use a pie chart to
visualize this right so here what you
directly see in this example is that
this pie chart looks quite messy quite
overcrowded the basic rule of thumb is
that whenever you have more than about
five elements to show pie charts are
quite difficult to work with because the
Elementor is getting too small to really
display them in a visually appealing way
so is it really that clear to you that
for instance product 9 is twice the
share twice the size of product 10. so
these relative differences in area are
not that natural to grasp and to
understand and often bar charts like
this as shown here on the right might be
a bit more of an intuitive way of also
really comparing even relative numbers
like this